Ramadan Vlog 3 heute habe ich entspannt
angehen lassen ich habe Teigtaschen
vorbereitet und ein habe ich schon mal
angebacken weil ich brauchte unbedingt
diese käse-enzähne bevor es stressig
wird Taschen habe ich bei meiner
Schwägerin abgegeben bin dann im
Ruhrpark weil das kriege ich es kitchen
coffee sonntags immer offen hat also
haben wir uns noch Cheesecakes und
Macarons mitgenommen ich musste die
strawberry cream dazu nehmen die
schmeckt eins zu eins wie Yogurette und
das ganze wurde Iftar mäßig eingepackt
hat euch dieses packaging an es ist so
wunderschön der Store hatte natürlich zu
wie war's dann eigentlich bei euch heute
mit der Zeitumstellung irgendwie kam ich
so ein bisschen durcheinander in meinem
Tagesrhythmus aber es heißt ja auch dass
wir eine Stunde länger Fasten müssen
aber es ging eigentlich ganz gut klar
heute ich muss sagen ich hatte schon
gegen 19 Uhr extrem Hunger ich habe dann
zu Hause noch die Teigtaschen zu Ende
ausgepacken und habe sie mit zu meiner
Schwägerin genommen und die hat richtig
lecker aufgetischt das war alles so
lecker ich finde auch so langsam gewöhnt
man sich wirklich an die Fastenzeit und
trockenfasten ist ja sowieso die
gesündeste Art des Fastens das ist ja
selbst wissenschaftlich bewiesen wichtig
ist dass sie halt genug trinkt und ich
mache mir jeden Abend zwei
Wasserflaschen voll